all right
thank you for your patience
yeah
i want to welcome you to our event
a career master class
trending vijay who is the director of
i.t at honeywell welcome sean don
introduce the top
mastering the
art of digital technology leadership
and
just let you know
using webex controls you can put
questions in for chandan into the q a
function and we'll log those
for the questions toward the end of the
webinar
you can chat as well
but best to put the questions into the q
a for us
we will be doing a couple of polls and
one of these
start right now
and
the question is what's your level of
experience your work experience
we also asked how you're doing today
because we've been asking that
throughout the pandemic to make sure
that
you have an idea of how people are doing
with all the changing rules lockdown's
coming and going
surges
surging and receding
got another 15 seconds or so
and we'll close the poll in five
four
three
two
one
and
here are the results
so we have a
bimodal audience for each john and we
have
uh about a third of the people with 10
years or more experience we have a third
of the people who are
still in school
and
uh everyone else is kind of evenly
distributed between
and the good thing of course is that
uh almost everybody is in the
doing well or doing okay category
we hope that what you have to say
will help improve the
outlook for the people in the third
category there so
without
further ado let's
introduce you
the director of it at honeywell you're
going to give a more thorough
introduction but i just wanted to say a
few things
a digital
technology leader who is very well
qualified to talk to this particular
topic
um
he's focused on applying the
technology
to
improve all of our lives and
he has previously been with cognizant
and ge
and he will
talk a little bit more about himself so
i'm going to
stop sharing my screen and allow him to
share his
and
you will be able to start the
presentation
chose to work
okay one moment and i will transfer
all right sean you'll be able to share
your screen now
perfect
[Music]
uh let me know if you can see my screen
uh sharing the presentation so hopefully
you should be able to see that
yep we are seeing that
all right so uh
hi everybody i know it's a pretty late
in india time at least
so thank you very much for your time and
patience to come for this webinar
and hear me speak i'm not a master of
digital technologies so i don't claim to
be
an expert but i'm again a practitioner
though for a fair bit of time
and i've been most of my career journey
has been the g 17 plus years starting
2003 till 2020 i joined cognizant
in late 2020 and
only earlier this year i've joined
honeywell
as a director of yt so this is my
brief career journey i enjoy cooking i
enjoy
uh if i recall
games on xbox or consoles
i like reading fiction uh my favorite
author is
frederick forsyth i enjoy photography i
used to have
quite a bit of collection of lenses and
slr cameras no longer anymore now world
has changed
steve jobs one of the top most
digital technology leaders have to call
a product leader has changed the world
by bringing in camera and your phones in
the hands of pretty much everybody
and thereby eliminating the need for
carrying those bulky cameras
and lenses
and giving you an opportunity to capture
anywhere anytime
so brief summary about myself i'll move
into the main topic for the day
technical glitches
uh so i'll start the topic which is
mastering the art of digital technology
leadership
when you look at this
picture
i think what is on the left hand side
the image clearly shows
a leader or a person
or a personality having
multiple arms doing multiple tasks
together
that's what literally our digital
technology leader encompasses in today's
tech world
they are
required and bound to do multiple jobs
at the same time
they're multi-talented personalities
which lead and which execute several
things at the same time
so
taking
more into details
stewart if you are not able to see the
presentation just let me know because
i'm in presentation mode
and
yes i i'm hearing you um i think you for
i will send a message to people who are
having trouble
sure
so let's let's talk about what is or who
is a digital technology leader now in in
today's world
if i have to compare with somebody who's
to be a general manager or a
or a vp or a
leader in a company several years back
or at least even if i talked with my own
experiences when i started my career in
2003
everybody was focused on what is called
as information management so your
your company is producing
data which you're saying trying to say
okay we're we're producing in such a way
that we call it information and we're
managing and you would have applications
to basically
input data into a system and then keep
it
as
the years progressed
from 2003 till now
it kind of changed from information
management to
it became i.t where people started
learning languages like okay java
your gsps your j2e came in and you start
making more applications which are more
bus style
and segregating the the business logic
into multiple tears your front end was a
different wires whereas your database
technology was different so that was an
era where technology played a big role
in driving information
then came in
around if i was saying earlier on 2010
2011
is when the digital started kind of
coming in
and we said okay this is now the time we
call it digital technology world
and that's how things have started
progressing now a digital technology
leader is somebody who understands
the three aspects he understands
technology he understands
what are the strategic
systems
or assets that needs to be built
and digitized that will produce business
goals much faster
in a more leaner fashion
and with less cost
so they're they're kind of like
building
things in an organization
which are in basically increasing
revenue which is giving
organic growth to the organization
and and somebody who kind of blends
leadership
be it
people management
be it setting up vision and strategy
be it
uh driving change be it communicating
the goals
and the objectives of the organization
blended with technology
and digital world now when everybody
says talk about digital it just doesn't
means
you're trying to digitize your systems
and your processes that are in the
company it is more holistically looking
at the overall organization what it is
doing
how it is doing
and thereby
eliminating the waste out of the
processes
simplifying the work creating a much
much more elaborate
and
enjoyable user experience for the
customers
as well as employees and that in turn
gives you the organic growth that the
company is looking
any
questions steward
no we're good
okay
so if we talk about a digital technology
leader right what are the broad roles
and responsibilities of a dt leader
in in in a just if i have to call
a digital technology leader
is supposed to drive a vision
and build a culture
which is more digital oriented and when
we say digital oriented means it gives
experiences connected experiences to its
employees to its customers
which is
more
leaner which is more simpler
and which kind of makes the life easier
for everybody who's who's
experiencing
through that digital journey
whether it be it if you talk an example
of supply chain or talk an example
of any data driven
organization
you have to think in terms okay if if
i'm building a data driven organization
what are the needs
what is my vision to build that
organization do i want to make
data available to people or should i
make products that give insights to
users who want to consume the data
thereby eliminating
what are the things
that are supposed to be built
so rather than
people
and
system to do the things by themselves
you're giving them an experience in
itself so thereby you're creating a
vision you're building a culture where
people are getting more seamless uh
cherished experience in the organization
again another responsibility of our
digital leader
is
how their employees become productive
now if you look at simply look at the
last three years right
before covet came in a lot of
organizations had their data centers on
premise
people used to work out of offices on
desks
they would have a pc
or a desktop on their desk
and you would walk into the office work
for those nine hours 10 hours 11 hours
god knows sometimes people would work
for 12 hours in shifts and then thereby
you had a different experience working
in an organization
when the covet came in
the world realized
you can't go to your office you can't
work
in those first three months or four
months in 2025 the call starting
february until i think may or june
organizations across the world
were scuttling
to make their employees productive and
how did they do it
they started either sending their
desktops to their employees homes
giving them connectivity at homes
laptop provisioning now you could give
an asset but what happens if your
organization's network can't support it
thereby organizations have to transform
what they want to do it in in next 24 to
36 months
they were able to accomplish that in
next four to six months
because they were realizing their
revenue was getting hit
their customers were getting impacted
their employees were getting impacted
thereby the organization had to
transform rapidly
and there came in the digital leaders
who said okay let's move things to cloud
native technologies
let's have service delivery events
uh
software driven network services
and that's how if you realized a lot of
organizations moved faster
and people were able to work out of
homes so digital technology leaders
responsibility is to make sure
their employees their team members have
the right tools in their hands
they're able to build and develop using
those technologies and become more
productive
so if you have to compare
march 2020 versus march 2022 in two
years time
[Music]
now the organization is saying no no
we'll move to flex working hours
because we realized
there's a digital experience that the
team
is there now
our employees can walk out of anywhere
which in turn
is
getting more productivity to the people
and the projects and the organization
it is improving customer satisfaction
and it is also increasing revenue
because now
you're paying less for facility promises
you're paying less for
a lot of other benefits that the
employees used to be provided while in
the workplace be it cabs be it your
coffee machines
just to name an example
and
thereby giving a much more leaner and
simplified experience
to the employees
another trait or responsibility of a
digital technology leader is
how do you improve customer satisfaction
by giving a user experience to the
customers which are which are simply for
simplified for them
which are easy to use
and which is technology driven
if you have to compare
a
banking
10 years back versus
five years back versus now
you would realize that the customer for
a bank has transformed a lot and so has
a banking organization
10 years back
if you wanted to like take the money out
you would have to go to the atm right
if you had to open a bank account you
would have to go and visit a branch or
somebody at least would come to your
home
and do that whole piece of account
setting up kyc
and then the account will be open you
will be dispatched
a physical card a physical pin by
another mail and you would have to go to
atm change your pins and so on and so
forth as times changed
banking became a little more simplified
you could just submit
uh certain documents through online
you would get your
card
still dispatched to your home
they had their digital assets which were
like the web-based portals
which could help you get account
balances change the pins and so on and
so forth
if you look at today's world right
there are banks in india which don't
have
physical presence at all
their entire world or their entire
banking runs on digital services
they're giving such a simplified
experience to the customers which are
like from our opening from a bank
account you submit all your
documentation
through a
mobile phone application
within a few minutes your account is
provisioned
basis of the kyc that you have done
through digital be it through aadhar
based linking
or be it through a pan based linking or
an itr that you're giving
and then the customer
gets
immediate services such as upi you can
transfer funds immediately
your your services are provisioned
within few minutes
so the customers life has simplified a
lot
with the
enhancement of technology
and by digitizing
the overall ecosystem
so it's not just how banks
have changed or digitized how they used
to work
they have literally
disrupted
how they used to work
no physical banking no presence point of
presence
and you just move on
and we work there
which is what is helping the fourth
point which is which helps organizations
increase the revenue
because if you're not spending
your money or your investments
in physical assets or in people
and is still offering the same services
as any other organization
you are saving dollars you're saving
money for your own organization
and last of the law not the least
a digital technology leader must
celebrate success
for his team for his organization a lot
of times uh
managers tend to
have large releases and you'd say hey
we've had a great thing but then you
just move on and we keep on working
a good dd leader
celebrates successes with his or her
team
and
kind of shares
the accountability as well as the
what do you what you would call if the
praises with the teams itself
i'll move into the next section which is
what skills would you need
for a becoming a dd leader
in the next
career span of let's say 12 months 24
months depending on where do you stand
in your career you may want to like pick
couple of those and say okay these are
the areas i need to focus because that's
going to take me to my next level
and then again you take certain more
points and you start working on
enhancing them to become a more
efficient dd leader
it's not just simply just technology
leader that is that is enough nowadays
by a digital technology leader you're
trying to understand your customer
you're trying to understand what is a
technology landscape
you are trying to
learn and
grow with the upcoming
technology landscape changes
and thereby offering services and
innovation and creativity
to your organization
to guide your team
that makes you more efficient
dt leader
i'll move to the next section which is
okay what's the key trade or skills that
you want to build
a good deity leader has a vision
for his or her team
is an organization
with a clear mind in its place that okay
hey this is
what has to be accomplished
if i have to become
a dd leader i'm laying down a very clear
road map for people to see
i'm clear down writing down what are the
priorities that we need to accomplish
and what will be the
if not the end goal
what is that we want to accomplish by
this year and
or in the next 24 months and where do we
need to stand
with respect to our competition
that vision is something that is an
important trait or a skill that our dd
leader must have learned
today's world you're not running a
project
it is more about how are you running
a overall ecosystem it is encompassing
of products you've got your apis you've
got your data you've got a big data
coming in you've got the social media
presence
a dd leader
looks at the larger picture creates a
vision
a direction statement
and shares with his her team
and an organization
and motivates everybody
to walk towards that vision
going to the next one
is
laying down a very clear strategy
is an important skill or a trait
of a dd leader
you have your vision
but if you do not know
what is my strategy to go
to that vision
there's a good likelihood that you would
fail because without having a clear path
laid out without having a clear strategy
of how i want to accomplish
do i need to do an inorganic growth
versus do i need to do an organic growth
those are some of the things
those are the things that as a strategy
the leader will have to look at it and
say okay this is what my vision is i'm
translating that into a road map
now to to meet that roadmap and to walk
on that this is what my strategy is am i
targeting on my id infrastructure
am i targeting my operations
am i targeting my supply chain am i
targeting my marketing and
design and sales teams or am i giving
power in the hand of my ceos and cfos in
the cxo group
to make decision making
by laying out a clear foundation through
a strategy the vision is what starts
getting translated into an actionable
items that you would want to accomplish
steward anything that
you want to talk
anything you want to bring in at this
point in time yeah i mean there's a
really interesting
question for um for you from my aunt um
which is how do you identify what kind
of digital technology is beneficial
for a particular problem
and
that's going to solve a problem for your
business when you enable it
i think it's a it's an interesting
question because
one
solution doesn't fit everywhere
so in in a near dt space
i think the fundamental part is to
understand
first what is the customer what is the
customer needing
what is the problem
that you are trying to solve
and instead of getting into a problem
solving mode
you start analyzing the information or
the data that you can gather around
with the two things that you know who's
my customer what is my customer's
problem
and by applying the data you're trying
to kind of associate and trying to
understand the kpis which will drive the
decision-making as to how you can solve
that problem
and by that means then you can start
thinking
how can i solve that
so let's say if you if you look at
let's say rural india right today's
world has got everybody's got a
smartphone in their hands
and if i
try to call the same thing right
a banking operation if somebody needs to
transfer
funds
there was a time when person has to go
to a bank and either give a check and do
that
whereas today
a lot of banks are offering digital
solutions
through their apps
or even through sms based services on a
feature based phone
so it's not that that you're just trying
to
solve a problem by fitting everybody so
let's say a person sitting in bangalore
or mumbai or delhi
would have a smartphone in their hand
where with a a nice looking app that
solution can be served
but if you come to rural india where the
connectivity is not that great
people might not have the best phones or
the applications might not be that
stable
how do you give a service
to the customer
so then you are thinking through
differently
who your different customers are who
your target audience is and they're
trying to build a
solution i hope i answer that question
i think you did
we'll be getting to more questions later
in the
session
sure absolutely
okay the next one is communication now
this is uh
i don't know like
how many of you might have like heard
this thing communication is one of the
most important
if i recall trades for any
leader
and in especially in dt world the
communication is not just
downwards as a leader
it has to be upwards to your leadership
it has to be lateral and horizontal
across
and it will go beyond the organization
to your customers to your competitors
also
because now you're trying to communicate
in a 360 degree sphere kind of
environment
a dd leader is not just communicating
downwards he's he's communicating with
his seniors with customers trying to
gather as much information
so that will help
his or her team
to make a more
effort to call
data-driven
judgment
or a making
so communication is a very very
important trait if i have to call
being a great dd leader
you have to be able to communicate the
strategy you have to be able to
communicate the vision
you have to be able to personally
connect with
the organization the teams the customers
it's not just becoming like okay you're
just sending me meeting minutes and all
how do you building relationships that
will give you more meaningful
insights be it your customers be it your
peers be it your
competitors because you're trying to
understand how the market is happening
and how how the dynamics might change
and how do you influence
the external factors
and that happens when you are able to
effectively communicate
what is that is
in your vision what is in your
uh strategy
even even if it if you're a middle level
manager
you're not a very very cxo level kind of
a person or a director or senior
director
but you intend to grow in an
organization communication is one of the
most important aspects
of delivering the message in the most
concise manner
creating and building relationships
with your peers
with your leaders
and thereby making it one of the most
important traits of any leader and even
in dt i think this is one of the most
important ones
if you look at the icon which shows it
is like
it's it's a it's a repetitive process
you are communicating and you're
receiving and you interpret that as a
feedback or you take insights out of
that and then you again
re-trade the information that you want
to share and then that that cycle keeps
on continuing as long as you're you're
delivering something and you're you're
motivating the people and moving forward
on your roadmap and you're changing the
strategy as you're as you're driving
that that road map
the next one is innovation now i think i
think uh
it's it's one of the most important ones
in a dd leader's
skill sets or traits as to how do you
develop innovation
creativity disruption
through
looking outside looking inwards
looking at your peers looking at your
competitors and saying
and also understanding how the world is
changing if you want to look at like the
the biggest innovator in our
generation
i think steve jobs is a perfect example
he literally changed the world
by the ideas that he had and by bringing
them on
and doing them
so that was
uh
that is one of the biggest traits that
he would look at that
if you look at like if you think about
apple as a product right when apple used
to sell
uh
max long back
there was one one problem with apple max
they never had a cd writer
and back in those days windows pcs used
to have
cd writers
you could just burn songs into your cds
and play it in your in your computer
apple didn't have that
and steeja said to help with that i
don't want to give a cd writer
on my mac because that product i like it
as is
i'm going to give world something which
is completely disruptive he created ipon
he gave the power of songs listening to
songs in people's hands that's how
innovation is how that's how disruption
is so a dd leader has to be looking at
how the world is
what the customer is expect expecting
going beyond it and then delivering
something
which makes
as i said the user experience or the
customer experience
absolutely memorized mesmerizing
absolutely cherished
uh stuart you have to give me one minute
i think there is somebody in the door
and my apologies everyone
uh please bear with me
oh okay no worries
this is what happens when we're all
working from home
true absolutely that is how the world is
so you have to bear with me please just
give me one minute okay
take a moment um
in the meantime we're getting uh
a number of questions and if i make an
announcement
the people who need to hear it won't
hear it which is uh
some people are having some audio
problems
uh which is a difficulty that we often
have with the webex platform i can tell
you that simply learn will be moving to
zoom in a couple of months but in the
meantime
if you've been having intermittent audio
problems please check your webex
settings
we also will be sending out a recording
of the
session so that you'll be able to
catch up with anything you missed
hi china
hey i'm back
thank you all right i have a question by
the way that came in um
and it regards the first thing you
mentioned which was vision and indramani
asks in in this rapidly changing world
how does
a digital leader
know
or recognize
his own vision his or her own vision
interesting one i think i think it's
again a very subjective one
because i think in in which industry you
are it all depends on that
if you're in the manufacturing industry
is there a way you can simplify
manufacturing processes
uh
not just by digitizing but how you can
change the process itself
for example even lean for that matter
[Music]
that is another uh
we
recall
integral aspect of a digital technology
organization
so
it all depends on where do you work
what
future
do you foresee could happen
if in 2019
i don't think anybody could have said
world will be running on
vpn or no vpn
and users or the employees of the
organizations
would not have to connect to vpn and
still be able to access a broad amount
of the assets that the organization had
right
now some of the some of the
leaders had the vision to say no we want
to change the world
we will give a much seamless user
experience to our employees
we'll give them laptops we'll give them
connectivity in such a way that they go
home turn it on
and everything is available on internet
which they primarily use be it emails be
it some other
non-confidential
applications of the organization and how
they do it they said okay let's move
everything into cloud
let's give more
simplified vpn solutions where people
don't have to enter username password
pins
uh it basically
authenticates through the pc or a
certificate itself and do it
those organizations who implemented it
couple of years back before covert hit
were the ones which were
the most
uh i i think i'd call that the fastest
to get back on their feet
and be able to like run
in the direction then they were supposed
to
[Music]
if and if i would give likes a simple
example again
i wouldn't call it a dt one but
in a lot of manufacturing facilities
there are systems which can produce
objects by a simple
changing the parameters or setups
for building one so fabric industry is
one
when cobait hit
a lot of small organizations which were
making
uh basic stuff
they transformed their
supply chain they transformed their
processes of manufacturing
to build mosques
and you everybody knows right in the
first
one year of covet mask was a very
integral thing
so just by changing their
system
of manufacturing and the process of
manufacturing
they were able to produce
something which was
needed in demand and then therefore they
were able to
give a better customer experience which
is like people were able to get more
masks in their hands
and at that point of time musk was a
commodity which was selling like
hotcakes
therefore the
organizations earn their revenue
so a vision is something
which
uh you have to understand what do you
foresee in your future
in your in your
domain and how something disruptive can
change that future
and that is something which you which
you say
is now my vision can i actually
accomplish it
and then you start strategizing in that
direction
you start laying out very clear
tactical items or
smaller strategic initiatives
which would drive a much larger
[Music]
strategic or tactical
execution aspect
hope i answered that question
okay moving on digital literacy now
what does this mean basically
back in uh 10 years back 15 years back
even even five years back for that
matter
a lot of business leaders would not
want to touch their hands with
technology
and
the leaders who learned
with the new era and they understood
what technology is
and how it might shape the future
they started understanding it and then
they started asking questions to their
organizations
how can this change help me or how can
this change
benefit my business process
or how can this technology make things
simpler
for what we're doing
if you if you look at simply like if you
if we talk about amazon right
on the
amazon when you place an order you're
able to track it all the way till the
time
the item is delivered to your doorstep
how does it happen
[Music]
somebody was able to say okay no i
understand phones are there and i
understand phone has got a camera
what if i use that phone and the camera
to literally scan the package at every
station that it goes through
which gives me my real-time data
and therefore i can basically track this
whole thing
and give a great user experience
the one person could think about phone
about that way the other person would
just think phone about okay no i'm going
to give this phone to a person
who's going to go deliver this package
to a person's home
he will call the
customer when he reaches the doorstep
and then and how to give that
so now these are two different
aspect of using the same technology so
the leaders who became more literate
about
digital systems digital technologies ai
iot
5g
anything that came in blockchain for
that matter
they were able to understand and start
asking questions about okay how does
this benefit me how does this benefit my
organization how can i make things
easier for my customers for my employees
and therefore make life simpler
for what my organization is is all
representing it
and and that is a big big trade that a
digital leader needs to have now
understanding what is
happening in the world in terms of
technology in terms of
digital transformation how organizations
are changing themselves
and then
targeting and then going behind it in an
aggressive way to make things happen for
their own organizations
and and while they're doing it
one of the most important aspect that
comes in is
with digital literacy you need to be
hands-on
you just can't be sitting on a fence
line
and directing people to say let's do
this let's do that
you need to be understand
how the paradigm change happens with the
technology
and we given again i'll give a clear
vision and a strategy
around that technology or around that
digital transformation
any questions toward any any comments
in the audience
we've got a number of questions but uh
i'll ask um
one of them um
i have an interesting question from nihi
who who
observes that multitasking
can often cause
different aspects of
your leadership to
diverge in in style or or in cost
and how do you try to keep a uniform
approach across the different
tasks that you have to to accomplish as
a digital leader
so if i understand the question what
is trying to ask is
multitasking can cause magnitude of
problems and how do you keep a uniform
approach right
yeah
okay
interesting question
and honestly i
i would say i have never multitasked
more than like two or three items
in my hand because typically human
mindset is
is
bound to remember two or three
at the most three
things
that have been communicated so if i'm
telling you those ten points today
the skills that you need probably a lot
of people might remember three or four
at the most five
and
if if i were to talk about multitasking
right
i've known a couple of multitaskers in
my organization
uh really good friends
they literally jot down
their tasks and their sequences
in a notebook
and then they literally execute on it
and then they keep on cutting those
things
and by doing that so let's say if i'm
having five things in my hand or six
things in my hand
i would write them down in a piece of
paper
literally saying i'm on a piece of paper
i would write down what all do i need to
do to accomplish those five or six items
in as much as detail as possible
and then while i'm executing it on those
i'll keep on check marking or ticking or
crossing them then this is what i've
completed
and if there is something uh
i'll at least like talk about some of
the junior leadership right a lot of
people sometimes have managers we have
got multitasking
i think one of the things that we have
learned
at least while working at ge at
honeywell
there is never
it is never wrong to ask your manager or
your leader
that if you're giving me those five
items
what is the priority
and when do you need them
that's one of the most important things
that is there
that you need to be able to like
understand a lot of times when people
are given tasks
they become great task masters but
they're never able to like
throw up on into there's a leadership
skill
because they don't simply ask a question
uh i'll give an example in back in 2005
we went for a
army style army run
camp
it was an orientation program which was
for three days
and on the first day
there was a lesson that we learned
there was a retired kernel he gave us a
task to do
and it was a very complicated task
there were several instructions given
a lot of these things given
and people were like supposed to make
into different teams and you're supposed
to make your own strategy come up with a
solution
and then provided to them
while that exercise was going on uh this
gentleman was like sipping his coffee
enjoying this day and we kept on
brainstorming on that and executing on
that for three hours
and then of which he asked us one
question he said
i observed one thing
none of you even came to me and asked me
do you already have a solution in place
or not
he said i'm your customer
or i'm your
manager
why don't you come to me and ask me that
do i have a solution or not
so again when you're multitasking i
think i think it's important to ask
what are the items what is it what are
their priorities
and when do you need them
because sometimes when you have been
given five items
maybe your leader doesn't want all those
five now he wants one
by tomorrow
and then the rest four by next monday
but since you didn't ask you didn't know
so i think it's very important
that you may want to become a great
multitasker
but
removing your
shyness or inhibition to go to your
manager to your leader and asking what's
your priority
tell me that
and then doing it because that way
you're able to focus
on
what's to be done importantly
yeah and that's a
good
observation with respect to the question
because the
the discipline of asking about
needs priorities and deadlines
helps to create that uniformity
of you know leadership style or
management style across
the group that you're they're you're
managing so that everybody knows what
they need to do when they need to do it
and
um
you get
um
or consistency in performance so that's
that's a very good observation so thank
you for that
absolutely
i'll move on to the next point okay
adaptability now pretty big uh
again trait or a skill
as to how do you flex your leadership
style
in changing environments
how do you
change your strategy
when the world is changing
even for sometimes you might have to
change your vision
that if
the world is changing this way
is my vision still viable
that means
accepting the failure
being ready for a change
and
moving forward with that
adaptability to your changing
environment to your changing
circumstances
is very important to grow as a leader
if all the organizations which were like
oh no kobet has just come in it's going
to be another three days three months
four months
we will continue to live the way it is
will not change our systems
infrastructure will not move the cloud
they probably would have been left
behind
they would have been hurt the most
whereas if you realize no don't made a
mistake we should have done this like
three years back
no we have not done it but let's make a
change
and do as fast as possible
in the three months or the four months a
lot of organizations were ready
with their infrastructure
even the service providers never
anticipated that they had to work really
hard for us to get it done
and
that's how the world changed
so
your vision had to change your
strategy had to change
you have to divert dollars from some one
place to another place facilities became
less and less important
your infrastructure became more so as i
was saying right a vision can have
multiple aspects what do you want to
focus on do i focus on my infrastructure
needs do i focus on my customer facing
systems do i focus on my employee
experience or do i give something to my
leadership to make a decision making
being adaptable to changing
circumstances in the world
in the environment in the ecosystem
that's that's another
key skill that a leadership developer
i'd like to make an observation about
adaptability and agility
at the beginning of the pandemic i
attended a webinar where people were
talking about their initial responses
and
one executive uh whom i can't trace down
her name but she said a classic thing
which is
if they had asked us
a few months ago to make sure everybody
could work from home we would have said
it would cost 10 million dollars and
take six months
when the lockdown happened it took us
three days with no budget
so adaptability
and agility are extremely important
true steward
uh next is agile
you can look at the skewed watch
that clearly tells
time is a dimension which
is very important in
digital transformations in digital
technology leaders
schedules
you might have to run agile
organizations
fail fast move fast
learn fast and deliver fast those are
some of the things that that we
typically look
in in leaders
who are really shaping the world today
and
by moving fast and by failing fast
they're realizing
something doesn't work let's just pivot
get into something which
which will work
and they're not trying to waste their
time trying to like
schedule and prioritize and then try to
gather information as much as possible
sometimes you work from a limited set of
data and you make a decision you pivot
for it
and you realize it worked it didn't work
and then bring your adaptability again
change your strategy move forward with
that
i know agile a lot of people must be
thinking about the agile mindset of the
framework
uh this is not that this is more about
how do you move fast in the organization
how do you
communicate your vision effectively get
a strategy which makes people
drive in that direction and how do you
pursue your objectives in the fastest
possible way
you can implement agile frameworks you
can do waterfall whichever way the world
wants to work that's fine the only thing
is how do you deliver fast
rather than believing in a big bang
approach
you are giving your customers a roadmap
and saying hey i'll start with these
three things
but i'm promising you in the next seven
months to nine months i'm going to give
you these all these 11 things and you
work start working on those
so those are the kind of thought
processes that you're giving you start
with an mvp and then you start
delivering to your customer to your to
your partners
and to the world
this is a big one
appetite for risk because
when we become risk hours that means
our decision making process goes
longer
we want to gather as much as data as
possible we want to get buying from as
many people as possible
get everybody on board
and then kind of execute it in a way
that okay even when you're executing you
are
risk covers you want to ensure that
everything goes for a perfect
whereas in today's world as i said fail
fast move fast
you need to be ready for
saying that hey it didn't work
i'm going to just abandon it and move
forward with the different idea or a
different feature
so you're releasing some
specific feature in an application which
you think is a great one
and your customers didn't like it
don't fit on it
don't waste too much time on it
it's a rescue talk didn't work out no
problems
let's get on to the next task or next
strategy on hand
and keep moving
because at more time you ponder on
okay i've
didn't work for me this time
how do i ensure that the next release or
the next item that i'm going to work
through
will be awesome
then you're increasing your cycle time
for
releasing
your vision or a strategy into an
execution phase
and thereby
dealing what you could have done much
faster
any questions steward
i'm sorry i have a hard stop in five
minutes so i'm i'm rushing a little bit
i'm a work meeting and i'm just trying
to like get through this
no worries i'm going to ask you about uh
communications um
we had some questions that came in about
communications and conflict management
so
can you comment on
top down versus bottom-up communication
and how
the communications and in digital
leadership
uh
reflect on the skill of conflict
management
okay so one is top-down communication
the other is bottoms of communication
and
how does that help in conflict
resolution
yeah
okay
great question
now honestly i mean if i look at those
two kind of communication styles right
one is
then you have a vision when you have a
strategy when you have a direction
that can never come
from
a bottoms-up approach
because if you are an organization
leader
it's your responsibility and it's your
duty
to build that vision and to communicate
it effectively to the entire
organization so that they can start
moving in that direction
because that's
your interpretation of how you're going
to get revenue how you're going to get
your brand value
what you
are going to get into the market what
your go to market strategy is
so that's that's one aspect of a
top-down approach
if i understand what my customers ask is
then i would actually go and communicate
in the most effective way of what needs
to be delivered
whereas
if i'm looking at a bottoms-up approach
right
i may be able to like get more
beneficial ideas from a lower rung
[Music]
uh
in terms of from a customer experience
perspective
right because the
developer who's building that aspect
he or she may have
an idea about how to simplify
the work that they're doing
they probably might not be able to
effect or impact
the vision or the strategy or the
revenue with their idea but they can
definitely
have something which is
okay how do i
improve
the release time for this product
or how i can make
a component which is used across 10
different
elements within one product or a
different product
so bottoms up approach is great when you
want to get feedback
when you want to get ideas from people
because it's not always necessary that
the great ideas come from talk
but the top down is important when it
comes to vision when it comes to
strategy when it comes to direction
when it comes to
making everybody align behind one common
vision and direction
now when it comes to conflict management
right
there are times where
somebody has to put the foot down and
say
stop arguing figuring about and somebody
has to make a decision on top because
the person or he or may she may
understand
the broader aspect of a decision making
so let's say three other developers are
having conflict about what
feature should go into the application
[Music]
now because the developers would not
have an understanding
which a product manager or a chief
product officer
might have had
a top-down decision making in that
conflict would be beneficial
whereas
in a bottoms-up organization when you
want to do collaboration
that is where i think it works out
better because
you are trying to get ideation you're
trying to get ideas
and you're creating an environment
which is not shutting down anybody
it is not a decision-making
point of time you are trying to get as
much as
let's say what could be the features
what could be ideas how you can enhance
something
in the bottoms of communication you're
trying to get people
more understanding about okay what can
you tell us
what is
what is to be decided and what is it
which is sometimes more on the top
driven so i think i think you can manage
conflict uh by having both kind of con
communication styles
by working backwards or down down to up
by gathering ideas by getting
suggestions
uh try and filter them down as they come
up because as a leader you don't want to
have a list of 10 000 ideas
somebody
has to basically say no this is
i've got like consolidated these 1500
now when i have to go to my vp
they need to be 150 when the vp takes
two that says cfo it needs to be
15 when the cfo
meets with the chairman and the board of
directors they say okay out of the 15
we're gonna pick five and then let's
prioritize which of those three
which we will work
so you see how how a road map
is driving a feature
to a strategy to a item which is more on
the vision side so that's how bottom to
top can can work and when those
1500 filters down to 15 it becomes
responsibly the top most leaders to tell
you what that vision is what that
strategy is why we're doing it what
revenue is going to bring or how
employee productivity gets enhanced how
you're flexible working from home might
get better so there are different
aspects of those communication styles
i hope i hope it makes sense
yeah it does absolutely
so let's uh finish up the last two here
yeah last one and then i'll let you go
sure uh the last one is an eye for
talent i mean that's a bit it's a very
very important
aspect of a leader
several days back my
vp told me one thing i'm hiring you
because i think you're smarter than me
and that that line struck with me for a
very long time
because either like i know
certain things in business i don't know
certain things in technology but i know
you are great in technology are great
and in these three things and i know
you're better than me and that's what
i'm telling you because
i am planning for my own succession
planning
so i need to be able to hire those
people who should be able to take my
position
either when i move on when i move up or
a bus hits me
so
important aspect when you're hiring
at any given level in your organization
are people
who may be smarter than you
because that way you're building an
organization which is performance driven
which is talent driven
and where people will know that when
they've hired you
and when you have heard them
that you respect them
that's why you hired them
and that that brings a lot more
camaraderie that brings a lot of
collaborativeness
i hope that uh
helps someone i unfortunately don't have
time for questions
but if you want to understand another
session someday
i can try to do that
that would be wonderful
thank you so much i will um also answer
a couple of the questions that have come
in but uh i really appreciate you taking
the time today and um i will share with
the audience how they can get in touch
with you through linkedin and that type
of thing so
um again thank you so much and um if the
rest of you will stay on for a moment
we'll finish up the webinar
so
um
appreciate your time and
good evening and good night
and thanks for my really my apologies i
have to rush out
no worries
um
and i am putting into the chat
chundan's linkedin
there we go
there we go
and you'll be able to reach out to him
on linkedin i do want to mention one
thing about the last thing he said which
is about the eye for talent there's a
story about one of the
great
advertising agencies of the 20th century
where the owner david
ogilvy would give each new employee
a
russian nesting doll you know those
types of dolls that have a doll inside
and then another doll inside and then
another doll inside and
i think my video is frozen so i'll keep
that off
um
but
in the in most
innermost doll was a message like a
fortune cookie that said
if we hire people who are
less than ourselves we will become a
company of midgets if we hire people who
are better than ourselves we will become
a company of giants
and that's exactly what
chandan was saying
which is
hire people who are
smarter than you better than you
and your company will get
that much bigger your team will get that
much
stronger
um
we had a question from deepa who asked
about the difference between digital
literacy and digital skills
and
take on that is that
digital literacy is understanding what
technology can do
um digital skills
is understanding how to make technology
do it so
sometimes a leader doesn't need to know
how to make something happen doesn't
need to know how to to do the coding or
the configuration
a leader always needs to understand what
the capabilities are
so that
they
can reasonably evaluate
what their team is doing
the example from amazon is great because
if you're
digitally literate
as chunden said you understand that a
smartphone is not just a voice
communication device
it's a
iot point of
information exchange so it can be used
to collect location data and identity
data
and a whole bunch of other things that
are important to tracking
the process of delivery so the digitally
literate leader understands that
and
then
works with the team to
define the systems that actually
implement that so i hope that clarifies
that difference
um
and
i would like to
finish up
with a poll
and let me share
the screen again
and
we'll get to
the correct slide here
so this poll asks what digital skills
are you interested in learning we talked
about we just talked about the
difference between skills and
literacy
give you about 40 seconds
so what are the tools that you want to
add to your
digital toolkit
and then also when you think about doing
that when would you like to start that
process
and about another 10 seconds
and we'll close the poll
here's the result
so about half of our audience is
interested in leadership skills in
business and project management
which is consistent with today's topic
about a third of you are interested in
digital marketing
and
we did have questions about
entrepreneurship
and how to take teams from your current
company
or how to build a team in a startup
that's similar to the team you had in
your current company
hopefully we can have
chandon and other
speakers who will talk on that topic and
keep you apprised of those opportunities
and
it's also
interesting to see
about two thirds of the audience was
interested in starting either right away
or within the first next three months
so we'll offer you ways to do that
um
again chandan has his
linkedin information in the chat but i
will put it there again just to make
sure that you've got it
so let me do that
and
i want to mention one of the uh
flagship programs that simply learn
offers in conjunction with purdue
university purdue is one of the leading
universities in the united states
and
actually has a worldwide reputation
and
together with purdue and kpmg the
leading consulting firm we've created a
program
for
training in digital transformation
this is an excellent
program
that is intended to give you
very strong digital leadership skills
and
it's appropriate for people who are
well along in their careers
and
it will help you take your career to the
next level so here is
in the chat a link to the program page
where you can learn more about
this particular program
and i do want to mention that our next
webinar in our series
is tuesday
of next week one week from today
this is a
master class for those of you who are
in software development in devops
and
if you're not but you have
friends team members colleagues who are
please let them know about this
class